I used to feel super guilty when I wasn't with my kids either,
and feel like I shouldn't be having fun,
I shouldn't be doing anything.
But you know what I started to do was tell my kids about what I did.
Like, when they come back,
I want them to know Mommy's still a person and has a life.
And so I'll be like,
guess what I did?
Mommy went to the movies, or Mommy went to a concert,
or Mommy did this or Mommy did that.
And when I look at it as a way that I can bond with them,
that I can get them,
you know, like, that object permanence.
Like, just cause you're gone doesn't mean mommy's life stops.
Mommy totally has a life.
Like, I've gone to travel while they're gone.
I've gone to New York City and come back with souvenirs like, hey,
well, you guys were at Dad's house.
I was in a whole another state.
I wasn't even anywhere near you guys.
Isn't that cool?
And so I use it as an opportunity to show them that mommy has a life.
You know what I mean?
That Mommy is a person.
Mommy has other things she can do.
And then I look,
I. You.
I look at the time when they're away
as an opportunity to do something cool
to talk to them about.
So, um,
I don't know, maybe you. Could you do that a little bit to help?
Because you Know,
it doesn't help you or the kids
to stay sad the whole time they're gone.
Especially when they're gone for five days,
seven days. It's only gonna draw the time out longer and exhaust you.
And that's the goal.
The goal is to drain you of all of your love and support.
But the thing is,
you're not a narcissist.
You don't receive all of your fucking energy
from someone else's supply.
You can just create energy.
You can create happiness and love.
Like, you can do that for yourself.
So lean into that.
And it really helps when the kids are